actually if you want to deploy it for
gamma equals 0.9 or 0.95 you actually
train it for gamma equals 0.8
or 0.7 that's actually generalized as
well so this is an interesting paper by
nan jiang from his phd thesis i think
man gave a talk here yesterday
on a different topic so so that that's
i don't know if people have looked into
it much um so so
just one i mean if you use a smaller
gamma i guess there is an advantage
it'll converge faster
and if you have a small amount of data
it generalizes better this is sort of a
high level intuition although i don't
know the details of it yeah apparently
this is what people do in practice
so but this this is you don't need to
you know
yeah yeah that's that's that's what i'm
saying the connection is it's kind of
interesting
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it might be
interesting to sort of
uh compare that or you know point out
that it doesn't really you don't really
need to do because i guess one question
i've always been confused about is what
what gamma should you choose
i mean right yeah yeah i think this work
shows that it does it shouldn't matter
the risk one factor shouldn't really
that's that's interesting yeah
yeah okay so our next speaker
my old buddy from illinois uh suicant
so he's very well known in communication
circles
expert in game theory and if you go to
his bio
um the you know i mean
his interests are so broad you can't
even uh uh
list it all um he's got some stunning
awards and he's a
a chair professor at the department of
electrical computer engineering in my
hometown
urbana-champaign and at the coordinated
science lab
um i'll let you go sir thank you very
much sean thank you for the invitation
to come to this workshop it's especially
an honor to be introduced by sean i was
a graduate student when sean arrived at
illinois and he was one of my heroes
and it's uh delightful to be here the uh
session chaired by him and it's also
particularly uh
interesting to be in the session where
shawn gave a talk which
and anna was supposed to give a talk and
i did i gave a talk because some of my
work
in this talk or the basic the proof
relies on some of the earlier work
um so this is a paper that will appear
in europe's uh this year
and uh the title of the talks the mean
square
error of wq learning i think all of you
know what q learning is
and probably some of you may have heard
of double q learning so i'll talk a
little bit about what double q learning
is and
what we did to compare double queueing q
learning and q learning
so this is a joint work with uh venta
wang who is a
super amazing kid from chingua
he he is he was a junior when he visited
me he's just starting a senior year at
chinwa
he'll be applying for grad school this
year and he already has two papers and
segments
one in europe's and uh yeah he has
probably already published more papers
than many phd students by the time they
graduate
he's from the yao class which you
probably know what they are classes at
chingwa
my colleague was actually moving to eth
computer science department
next week and and laying from the
university of michigan
um so i guess i won't give much of an
introduction i think in this audience
everybody knows what we are dealing with
so we have a dynamical system
and we are interested in in this
particular talk i'm interested in
maximizing a reward which is a
discounted reward infinite horizon
discounted reward
and i think we all know the q learning
algorithm so so we have the bellman
equation
for the state action value function q
and if the conditional expectation can
be calculated so when i was in grad
school and
people used to teach stochastic control
i guess we used to
assume everything was given and we used
to figure out you know we're told that
this is a
contraction mapping so you can just uh
um you know recursively solve this
of course these days the cool thing to
do is of course assume that you don't
know the probability transition matrix
and so you want to try to solve this
from a trace or from
from simulation data
so one thing to point out here is uh so
there have been many techniques
which have been uh studied over the
years to improve the performance of q
learning
and in particular double q learning is
one of these techniques which
which looks at the bias sort of i'll
talk about it in the next
slide as to you know when we're
estimating this max
from empirical values of
q what we are really interested in is
max of the expected value of this
quantity but where we only have
empirical estimate of q and so we are
trying to do this
and so the question is you know how
badly or
what what is the impact of doing this uh
here's an interesting example i think
this
problem was first identified by hedo van
hesselt in a
2010 europe's paper and this example
by in saturn and barto's uh book uh
sort of you know gives a very nice
explanation for what's going on here
so let's say you're in state a so if you
go to the
right you get a reward of zero but if
you go to the left
you get a reward of minus one it doesn't
matter what action you take there are a
bunch of iid random variables that
reward for each of those transitions
this
gaussian random variable with mean minus
point one and variance one
as you get you get a negative reward if
you go to the left but on the other hand
what does q learning do
q learning operates using an estimate of
these quantities
right so it's possible that the maximum
of these quantities is positive
so you'll keep going to the right
initially so so the question is how long
does it take for q learning to
learn to go to the right but but in
reality
it will start going to the left
initially for a long time i mean we know
from q
learning convergence theory that it will
eventually converge at least in the
tabular case
but but if you look at the so what
sutton and barto plot is look at the
number of epic
episodes and how often do you go to the
left okay so that's what plotted on the
y-axis
and if you look at q-learning initially
actually it goes to the left a lot
okay and gradually it learns to figure
out you should go to the right okay so
the question is
can you fix this problem can you figure
out can you do something about this
maximization bias as they call it
so here is the intuition and of course
what is implemented is a heuristic
so here is an intuition so the idea is
that you want to estimate the maximum of
the mean of
a bunch of random variables and let's
say you have 20 samples each from each
of these random variables
one way to estimate the max of this
quantity is to just
take the empirical mean of each of the
random variables and just take the max
okay let's just say for you know
simplicity you have 20 samples
another way to do it would be to divide
the 20 samples into
batches of 10 each okay so you take the
20 samples
take just 10 of them and use them to
estimate
the empirical mean okay and then find
whichever random variable has the
largest mean from this empirical
estimate
and then estimate max of i of expected
value of y i
by computing the empiric by by looking
at the empirical mean
of of i star okay so this is the second
way to estimate it so i hope everybody
understands the first way to estimate
this
is just simply looking at all the
samples the second way to estimate it is
that divided into two batches
use one batch to figure out which the
maximum is and then estimate the mean of
that maximum
okay so what van hassell argues is that
the first estimator
overestimates and the second estimator
underestimates
and so he suggests using something
motivated by the second estimator
because these are not iid random
variables i mean queues are just
estimated in
using stochastic approximation so here's
the heuristic
that he suggests so traditional queue
learning is this
so you have a single estimate of of the
q function
which you're using in the right hand
side so basically if i
if i take the q here and move it inside
the alpha basically you're comparing q
with itself in the future right
whereas what van hassle suggests is that
the simple iid example suggests that
actually your actions should be separate
from your estimator
so what he says is that you know what we
should be doing
is we should have two estimators
one which is used to figure out what
your optimal action is in the next stage
and when you're using the bellman error
comparison you have to compare it to the
other estimator
this is just purely a heuristic
motivated by the discussion in the
previous page which was also provided in
his paper
and so basically q learning takes more
space in the sense that because you have
to maintain two queue estimates
but in this example in the sutton
embardo paper double so this is called
double q learning by the way
so it's called double queue learning
because you're maintaining two estimates
of the q value
double q learning actually dramatically
improves the performance of q learning
okay and this has been studied in a lot
of examples so people
so original the original band hassle
paper was for
tabular queue learning and then people
have used it in
for large scale stochastic control
problems where you're
estimating the q function using uh deep
neural networks and so on and i've
visited
companies where people use wq learning
and they tell me that converge is much
faster and it also
leads to some stability i mean it makes
when you have a when you have a neural
network in the loop it actually makes
the convergence of the neural the neural
network training part better it's
basically what i've heard anecdotally
but it's also not difficult to come up
with examples
where the maximization bias doesn't
matter let's go back to the
sutton and barto example suppose i
replace one of these
uh quantities one of these
rewards by n point five one so so in
this case going to the left
is the optimal thing to do because there
is an action on the left that gives you
a positive reward whereas going to the
right gives you zero reward
so yeah so according to van hassel's
paper there will be a maximization bias
but the maximization bias does doesn't
affect us you're actually going to the
left is a good thing to do in this case
so so you can come up with examples
where actually q learning performs
better
than double q learning so one of the
questions we had we were thinking about
was you know is there a way to actually
make double q learning perform
as well as q learning when q learning
performs well but then
it also improves the transient
performance when q learning does not
perform well
and one of the things we observed also
is that in these cases where q learning
performs well it also performs well
in terms of asymptotic mean squared
error so this is the connection to
aditya and shawn and
chen and and uh and abuse it just work
so we thought okay why not compare the
asymptotic mean square error mean square
error of q learning and double queue
learning and try to understand under
what conditions
and how do we choose the step size of
double queue learning so that
it it it matches at least the asymptotic
mean square
of q and q learning in all the examples
that we tried out it seemed like
a double q learning seemed to have worse
asymptotic performance even though
sometimes the transition performance is
much better
so we thought maybe if we can match the
asymptotic mean squared error
and and then hopefully those same set of
parameters if it also works well for
transgender which we cannot transition
analysis which we don't know how to do
uh uh then maybe there's something
interesting to learn here so that's sort
of the motivation for this
work so our goal is to
use a symptomic mean squared error
symmetric and i put some question marks
here because i know we all use a
sympathetic mean squared error but
people
you know always complain saying that you
know you're not really interested in
estimating the q function you're really
interested in learning the optimal
policy and i think
i touched upon this in the last uh uh
talk a little bit
and and so the question but but you know
i don't know any other metric to
to compare so i'm going to use symbolic
mean squared error
and derive conditions on the learning
rates so that double q learning at least
just the same asymptotic mean squared
error or sq learning
and then experimentally check you know
how does this
how does this learning rate compare okay
so i haven't i haven't tried zap q
learning or whether there's the
equivalent of zap q learning for wq
learning and so on that's an interesting
question that i haven't
addressed here so motivated by this
paper by devraj in maine
and you can go look at that paper for
conditions so
basically i'm not going to look at q
learning i'm just simply going to look
at td learning
and and so you assume a fixed policy and
then you compare
double q learning double td learning
with double with
single td learning but of course then
the question is which policy
should you use to compare because i mean
the the comparison makes sense if you
use the optimal policy but since you
don't know up the optimal policy how do
we compare
but we establish a result that holds for
all policies and so so it will also hold
for the optimal policy
and we'll use linear function
approximation this top of course we've
done some experiments with
neural networks but that's just a
heuristic so we'll use linear function
approximation
for this for this talk so in other words
we're approximating the value function
as we all know
as some theta transpose vi where vi is a
known feature vector whose dimension is
typically smaller than that of the
state and and this is uh sutton's famous
uh td learning algorithm so basically
look at the
error in the bellman equation and then
move it along the direction of the
feature vector you move theta along the
direction of the feature vector okay of
course the special case here is that
if you use a vector with all zeros
except in one place then it reduces to
tabular td learning
uh of course it's a cyclist android
pointed out and and successfully
utilized the
property here that if you look at it as
a function of theta as a linear function
so this is a special case of what one
might call linear stochastic
approximation
so you can write it in the form theta k
plus one is theta k plus epsilon times
some a which is dependent on the
underlying markov
chain times theta k plus b of x k and so
if
if a bar the expected value of a in
steady state is for which
then this then this equation will be
well behaved and you can study its
properties
so if you if you write double q learning
and remove the max
from the equations then this also is
linear in the parameters theta a and
theta b
right so one can also use linear
stochastic approximation
results to study this to study uh double
td learning
and so so all i'm saying in this page is
that you can you can now also write it
in the form of a linear stochastic
approximation
and you can study the asymptotic mean
squared error of linear stochastic
approximation
which has a long history going back to
work on stochastic approximations
there are results in uh benvenis and his
co-author's book and recently
chen deveraj busine you know further
analyze this in the context of
uh reinforcement learning
so i'm interested in the asymptotic mean
squared error so that's it for the
for for td learning it's just simply as
as
i had already mentioned it is k times
expected value of theta times plus theta
okay i'm just going to assume theta star
is zero if theta star is not zero we can
just subtract that
and for double td learning there are two
estimates
for double q learning there are two
estimates and you can also instead of
outputting the estimates you could also
take the average of the two estimates
and
you know use that as your output so we
are
we're interested in comparing these
three quantities
to this quantity here and and of course
these two are of course going to be
equal so you can just think of because
because it's symmetric so so i guess
yeah so in double q learning there are
two estimates that you maintain
and of course by symmetry the asymptotic
mean squared error of the two of them
will be
the same so really we are interested in
this one this one
and this one okay
so our main result is that if you use
twice the step size of standard q
learning
for in double q learning then the
asymptotic mean squared error of double
q lending where you take the average of
the two outputs
exactly matches that one of that of q
learning so so
if there are cases where you're worried
that you know by using double q learning
you might actually do worse
it doesn't happen if you use twice a
step size for double q learning
and and of course if you use only one of
the outputs of wq learning you can
actually prove that
the symptomatic mean squared error is
strictly less okay
so if i have time i'll give some
intuition as to why why this is
uh true but first i'll just
give some examples so this is a
well-known example this is baird's
example where
he came up with this example to show
that q-learning with function
approximation may not converge
the details of the example are not
important
so so here we have double queue learning
i mean we have a lot of plots in the new
rips paper comparing it to q learning
double q learning various other
algorithms but just for simplicity for
this talk i
if you want to look at the new tips
paper you can get more information
and here's our uh proposed step size
rule
and you can see that it actually it
seems to perform better so this must be
an example where q learning actually
does better
and so basically by by doing this uh
doubling the step size
you actually get better performance than
the double q learning
um so this is another example this is
grid world basically you have to go from
s to d
and then there are some rewards
associated with the actions and there's
some probability of
moving depending on what action you take
and the previous example was
yeah was a was a linear function
approximation example
so here's an example with tabular q
learning and here again
with our step size rule dequeue with
averaging performs
uh um better than dq with a twice a step
size especially initially
and here's an example even
asymptotically where saying we increase
the number of samples
uh double q with with averaging with uh
you average the output and using twice
the tip size actually gives much better
performance in dq
and and the newer viewer suggested doing
some more examples with neural networks
and so on which we have done some of
that
and uh uh the basic idea seems to
continue to hold
although we haven't done google-sized
examples i guess we haven't done very
very very large examples with deep
neural networks and so on
okay so in the remaining time
i will give some intuition as to why
uh um you know how we did the comparison
between double q learning and q learning
even
so basically it is well known that if
you have a stochastic approximation
algorithm of this form
under some conditions the asymptotic
variance or asymptotic mean
squared error satisfies this leoponov
equation
okay where a is the expected value of
this quantity
now as i mentioned earlier standard td
learning can be put in this form
so so i can you can use the same
expression in the previous page to
compute the symptotic mean squared error
or okay so this is a synthetic this is a
covariance form to compute the mean
squared error you will take the trace of
this matrix
right so the covariance you can compute
for standard td learning and
and it will satisfy some aliyah equation
and similarly for double q learning you
can write you know you can you can
figure out what the what the lyapunov
equation for the problem is these are
complicated equations with no closed
form expression so the question is how
do you compare
the performance of q learning and double
q learning so the first thing to notice
is that
because of the symmetry of double q
learning the double q learning maintains
two estimates in qa and qb
and they're basically symmetric one
thing i forgot to mention is that you
flip a random
number a bernoulli random variable and
then if the bernoulli random variable
comes out
zero then you update the first one
otherwise you update the second one but
nevertheless it's symmetric
asymptotically both of them will have
the same
covariance so therefore for double q
learning there is a particular structure
into the covariance matrix that's the
first thing to notice
and the second thing to notice if you
look at the a matrix for
single q learning and double q learning
you will notice that the a matrix for
single q learning
if you call that a 2 minus a 1 meaning
the first term i'm calling it a
a a 2 in the second term i call a 1.
the a matrix for double queue learning
actually
involves exactly those terms except for
it in some funny order
so the matrix for the a matrix for wq
learning is minus a 1 a 2 a 2 minus a 1
times half
okay so there's a lot of structure in
in that allows us to compare the
solution of this
lyapunov equation and the solution of
this layout of equation
and so if you just use this structure
and and do some manipulations
you can see that the the if the if the
covariance of the
double td learning has this form
then you can show that v plus c over two
these two terms average together will be
equal to
uh uh the the the covariance of the
single q learning estimator i mean so
this is all even if it doesn't make
sense
what i'm saying essentially what i'm
saying is that there is a structure to
the to to
the linear stochastic approximation
underlying q learning and the linear
stochastic approximation underlying
double q learning you can exploit that
structure to get some relationship
between the solutions
of the lyapunov equations for for td
learning and double td learning
and now basically to compute the mean
squared error you have to take some
trace and so on and then
and then some manipulations and very
simple calculations but but i think the
clever thing
was uh that that uh um went out notice
was actually to
to to uh use this use this structure
and and and so what what you can prove
is that the
the asymptotic mean squared error of the
average output meaning if the
theta a and theta b are the two outputs
of double td learning or double q
learning
and then you take the average of that
and then that has the same asymptotic
mean squared error of
a single q learning but more importantly
this is a much
trickier thing to prove we can actually
show that if you use one of the outputs
of double queue learning it will not
it'll strictly be it's a sympathetic
mean squared error would be strictly
worse than that of
uh just q learning just doing q learning
alone
and to do that you have to show that
trace of v is larger than trace of c and
that's a much more
involved calculation
so i will uh wrap up here i was actually
i plan to talk for 25 minutes and and
uh so so i will do that so uh um
so we showed that an average estimator
of double q learning with twice the step
size
has the same asymptotic mean square
error of q learning and the motivation
was as i mentioned earlier
double q learning works very well in in
cases where there's this thing called
the maximization bias but you can easily
come up with examples where the
maximization bias doesn't hurt you
and in those examples q learning can
sometimes do better
and in all of these examples q learning
seems to at least in the examples that
we have tried of course it's not a proof
it's proved by simulation q learning
seems to have better
asymptotic mean squared error than
double q learning although double q
learning seems to have
typically better a transient performance
so the question was
can we come up with a step size rule for
double q learning that will match the
asymptotic
performance of q learning and and uh we
did that
and then of course the next question was
you know does it actually hurt the
performance of wq learning in the
transition phase
if you use the step size rule and at
least in simulations
it seems to not hurt so that's all we
can say at this point
um so this provides a possible step size
guideline for for double queue learning
and it's kind of interesting i mean you
know these
previous two talks made me think you
know maybe there's something else
also one should be doing such as apq
learning and whether there's a there's a
version of zapq learning for double q
learning and there are other things i
think there's something called target td
learning
and target queue learning which also
improve the performance all of this
basically
try to get on the fact that in q
learning we're we're working on with
estimates that are crude i mean at least
for a long time this would be very crude
estimates of the q value and what can we
do to sort of improve those crude
estimates
and and so there's target to td learning
there's something called dual linked
you know q learning and double q
learning we just focused on double q
learning for no particular reason
uh um and we were able to analyze it but
as i mentioned earlier one interesting
question i think that practitioners ask
is you know what is the point of
studying a sympathetic mean squared
error who wants to estimate the
q function anyway you are interested in
optimal policy
that's a valid question and it'll be
interesting to do some transient
analysis here
and and uh uh you know study non-linear
function approximation our results are
all true for linear stochastic
approximation
so non-linear function approximation
would be interesting to study
and maybe somewhere between transient
analysis
and asymptotic analysis lies finite time
analysis
and i just actually came across this
paper
which is also going to appear in europe
uh
so xiang zhao liang zhang liang is
also another grad student who was i mean
who was a graduate when shawn was a
professor
she's england liam who's at the ohio
state and
and uh uh sean was a professor at
illinois i mean
so in bing has this paper with her
co-authors on
finite time analysis of double q
learning where they instead of looking
at asymptotic mean square error they try
to get an expression or upper bound for
the mean squared error for any
any time i haven't looked at this
carefully so so i don't know what
what uh interesting information that
might uh
shed on the problem our goal was not to
just study q learning we wanted to
understand you know
can we sort of get at the benefits of
both q learning and double q learning by
looking at asymptotic mean squared error
whereas their
work seems to just primarily study
double q learning but but it might also
be i don't know if it'll
if you then compare it to other results
on on
uh asymptotic or finite time analysis of
double of single queue learning maybe
that will also shed some light on
what i'm talking about today that's it
thank you
nice work
any questions out there
um so um
by the way i i i think maybe not zap but
the relative double queue
that's right yeah too much overhead
correct
correct correct yeah but um but what so
what what's the step size
maybe i should something i missed so you
had a so it's g over
n plus one for for so this is true for
any g whatever appropriate g
you choose for q learning g over n plus
one and if you use 2g over n plus one
for double q learning it matches the
asymptotic covariance it's kind of
interesting
it almost feels like the average of
theta and theta b would satisfy their
own
third q learning equation exactly
exactly something like that
except that because these are not id
random variables it's kind of
complicated yeah yeah
through the intuition if everything was
id then then it's obvious
but if it's not id you have to go
through this complicated lyapunov
analysis to understand it if you don't
see a simple way although intuitively
that's what it seems like yeah the
correlation
yeah yeah that's right if you don't have
iid
uh flipping back and forth it'd be
impossible too yeah
that is another thing i'm saying that
but the correlation that the q function
estimator itself is not just a standard
law of large numbers but it's like a
yeah symbolic a lot of large numbers and
so so that's why we
go through this now it's remarkable that
the coin flipping doesn't hurt you that
it yeah
well the coin flip doesn't hurt you if
you do the average yeah if you do theta
a plus theta b over two
but if you just look at one of them the
coin flip hurts if you just
you that's if you just look at one of
them actually you can prove strictly
it's worse than
q1 yeah but surprise you can get rid of
it so easily that's cool yeah yeah
that is really awesome yeah thank you
god and um
i guess there is some question now i
don't know for whom oh yeah oh yeah
there's a q a there right
is it useful to go triple q learning
triple q
all right that is an interesting
question actually when my
student
gave this talk in his defense harsh
gupta bruce hayek my colleague
asked exactly the same question
why not use triple q learning i think
the idea is that
you're basically increasing the storage
by doing double q learning you're using
you have to store twice as many values
so you could do potentially triple q
learning
and then instead of using a bernoulli
random variable you can use a random you
know you can decide to flip a coin to
figure out which one you're going to
update so potentially it might help
but what is unclear to me is how do you
do a
so let me quickly show you what double q
learning is
so one thing that is not obvious is that
here uh
we are when we are updating the equation
for qa we use qb when we were using the
updating the equation for qb we are
using
uh uh so i don't know what happened
sorry yeah
so it's not clear when you have three i
don't know what you will compare here
i guess that maybe you could take the
average and compare i don't know
so one has to think a little bit about
how to use triple q learning if you were
to use triple q
but that is an interesting question and
somebody else asked the same question
oh there's another more questions are
coming in let's see okay
um oh there's another one here yeah uh
some can someone
oh thank you i wouldn't ask that too
i i i had the same question just now
yeah yeah i already worked with
vic burkar so okay
um i don't know i don't know it's a good
good question uh um that's that's a
interesting question i remember ben
talked about
i heard him give two talks on this topic
where you have multiple
q networks that you train and then you
keep switching between them and i can't
remember what it was was an alert on
plenary that he gave so i don't know
maybe it is related to that
i i don't know the answer to the
question is a very good question yeah do
you know you know
yeah yeah so that's actually i think
completely different sort of uh
so that's like if you're doing thomson
sampling uh in a bandwidth problem uh
you have a posterior
and then you try to sample the queue
function from this distribution
so that means they're maintaining
multiple q networks to essentially
um use it as a posterior on the q
function you know
instead of having a single queue
function so
that's more of an exploration problem
than i see and then they use
use something like boltzmann exploration
based on the school questions
so the sampling itself is the
exploration so you they sample one of
the q functions
let's say you have like ten networks
okay you sample one of them and then
you'll be greedy with respect to one of
them
but then you keep changing that yes i
teach in each of the episodes
it's you sample one of the uh okay it's
like a particle filter kind of a thing
yeah so that's a completely different
motivation yeah yeah yeah it won't
address this maximization bias that
um yeah i don't know if they're related
uh but the motivation yeah okay but this
is also interesting so this this
motivation is kind of
from the iid case but it somehow seems
to work for q learning so it'll be
interesting to understand
you know to make this motivation more
precise for for q learning
and there are places where q learning
does seem to work uh better
so so it's not clear how to but but
you're right i mean i guess
this question is valid so is there a way
to sort of switch between the two in
some way
yeah wild
okay well i guess so i guess there's
another question any ideas
of functional approximations um
we did our whole analysis for linear
function approximation for
non-linear function approximation i
don't know what to do at this point
um i don't know sean or aditya has some
well yeah but i think
i think well should i answer or should
you indeed yeah
you can answer i actually had a question
now i'll ask i'll just ask this to
srikant so this beds example it's
supposed to be a counter example how did
it converge i mean i saw that
uh i think we chose gamma smaller than
what it was
oh okay so the contour example is for
particular gamma okay
yeah sean can go ahead sorry but suppose
an equivalent question
so basically the asymptotic covariance
for like q learning
is basically the same as looking at the
linearization
it and that's that's for that you have
to analyze
tv learning with off policy
that's true and linearized so the
question is can you
use can you get a similar theory for off
policy tv learning
and uh wonder if you can that is an
interesting question i don't know
because that's that's because it's if
and only of basically i mean right
right once you can justify the
organization that you you know okay
but at least you can heuristically do
the linearization and see you know
what right now yeah so do you think
there's any hope for doing the off point
well i mean i guess
what what we are saying is that if it is
linearized if you use double the step
size it definitely both have the same so
if
you do linearize it but it's off policy
i mean it's yeah
policy okay yeah i don't think in
general it converges so
right right right so basically what
you're saying is you use one policy but
then but then
but then uh yeah yeah that's right if
you use one policy
you use it you use basically some some
trajectory generated by policy but then
do your q learning on that policy so
yeah
and i don't know
yeah no history it's a hard you know
it's a hard question there is something
called
there are some other versions of uh td0
that bhatnagar
has analyzed who's who was burkar
student he
he analyzed with sutton he analyzed a
bunch of versions of td0 trying to get
off policy td uh yeah gtd0 and gtd yeah
yeah it converges but it has like very
high variance so that's
what i think okay okay
sorry he'll stop sharing yeah um
okay cool so everybody out there it's
mandatory to come to the panel
you might have a break you're not
allowed to have a break now until uh
whatever it is is it noon i mean uh well
anyway for 30 minutes
25 minutes yeah 245 minutes and
coming to the panel it's going to be
great it's going to be a nice collection
of
panelists and it'll be fun and
well free margaritas for everybody
all right see you in a bit okay
you